I'm sitting on a fortune at heart you
might want a moment to use the restroom
now hello and welcome to the last
installment of quietly was homemade
Halloween costumes and I really would
call this I'm here with a mayoral and
today we've come up with a challenge
idea and it's called the pay off your
college debt by just making cheap
Halloween costumes challenge that would
take that centuries that no one on
YouTube is gonna want to title their
videos now this challenge is called the
mile across
doom check in front of me I have a
variety of items that you might be able
to find in your home without having to
go purchase them quick question
yes is this one of the props oh no this
is a gift
Shawn whiskey though oh they played the
mums Tamara here's how the game works
it's a little bit chopped and a little
bit homemade so there's gonna be three
rounds ten in total everyday household
items in front of us we have them all on
pieces of paper here in this jar each
round we will choose three except for
the last one they're looking for items
and we will be challenged with those
three or four items to create the best
Halloween costume that we can create
with our brain question yes are we all
doing the same three items every round
yes question yes do you know that the
mug not a jar question can you guys like
really oh yeah this is just what I keep
in my pocket really are there's no time
limit
oh I have a terror I just bought one
okay I get is not relevant because there
is
this is gonna take forever we can
pretend ready set low costume okay
oh we're all done yeah now it's time to
explain what we are Hannah would you
like to start since you finished so
quickly yes I would
using the toothpaste as an adhesive Oh
your average tax accountant oh but it's
not a pun it's mostly a pun
I mean it's hopeful that it will be okay
uh come on over and let me do your
Jackson's memory let's say you don't
know using go to toothpaste and the pen
to come I'm the Golden Gate Bridge
oh it's called it and it's like the
Golden Gate Bridge physical became bread
okay
I remember you can't read it on my hand
it says hello my name is Sean and I'm
gonna do this
puffy come for Colgate this is terrible
this is slowstar slowstar that was round
water so much oh my god how we all had
to watch top off because it burger maybe
while you were gone we made more shots
but the second tries to the fire it was
a graveyard smell what's in this
toothpaste in gum pitchman alright yeah
you did miss like a message of trying to
send book no but it you're like a free
whitening session at doctor
okay ready oh my god up steady low
costume practicing level there oh my god
what are you doing I have a plan I don't
even know I'm learning this is Betty
juvinity get the lipstick oh I'm just
chewing gum in it without lipstick I'm
not hairy for a date
grace you have to go through one layer
this I can't get it
Omar just opened there was not even a
safety device I'm having some homeless
fishes
try now are we all done yeah
wants to go first you know what I'll go
first cuz oh god they really comfortable
perfect my is the World Cup oh the
government oh oh
I'm a d-cup like Luke says are you also
just I'm a drug lipstick less your pun
oh offering you come let's become good
friends but like ah we stepped it up
I felt like Ron to was very rewarding
for all of us also what's in orbits
because I can't feel my toes
haha we're using the best items that are
left so we have toilet over my swag Oh
Raja was so much it was so much yummy
vice ready set low costume
hi-yah we can cut out because that's
gonna take me a minute is it
here we go first sure is the gum load
comes not part of it okay the tape is
part of it the tape is part of it yeah
I'm writing I got it I am a garbage bag
monster with a drill that favorite baby
that has touched you what for your
everyday bees can create stores I do it
up on I am mrs. Mellish oh that's really
good selling my mixtape ah I'm white
trash oh that works I thought I saw your
dumb ass just sharing with you guys
fellas that's out of the way I'm a good
worker per day yeah we all would like it
rejected members and stuff I also my
costume don't like it that ends low
costume
get your thumb now what you guys need to
do is in the comments below let us know
who won make sure that you go over to
Hannah's channel and check out my drum
pumpkin part 2 and make sure you go over
to memories channel just because hey
I don't know all right you want to
develop a safe word that if you need to
leave at any moment to fart you can say
it will stop what we're doing probably
to do that whenever I can't see is
actually a bunch of kale my farts are
rocking like a Beach Boys concert
meanwhile I got a oscillating fan to my
left just ready to knock out these two
girls in one fell swoop let's make a
safe word okay oh no okay I don't know
Anna please birth yourself out of that
right now
that's your friends they played the mums
to mash it was a graveyard